hi I'm sorry for the abrupt ending of
the
film 9A
but we've had some
very unusual main power cut
they say that it's a power cable
underneath the ground that's uh shorted
out and it's a major problem and I think
generators are going to have to be
brought in so
so just so you know why the film has
ended in an odd way
so I'd like to just summarize because
I've just made nine films this is we'll
say the the nine and a half
and it's for the people in the
organization the t-i-a-e
it's for all ranks it doesn't matter
what whether your Q grade beginner back
about
the most advanced black belt sixth Dan
I want to summarize
so you may wish to look at all those
films but I sent the letter out asking
down grades and Club leaders to notify
all the students in the clubs to decide
um
what they thought about us leaving the
TAA it's an American organization
and we've been part of them since 2007.
I feel as if we've been me personally
has been
treated rather shamefully
and I don't want to really go into that
unless you want to personally know if
you do email me contact me or talk to me
on a seminar and we can go into it
this September I should be
enjoying my 50 years in Aikido sounds
crazy Look At Me Now nearly bored and 50
years ago I have a picture of me inside
her Sensei with with an afro hairstyle
but my mind is still Keen I talk to
people around the world every day about
Aikido I think about Ikea every day and
it's um a bug that's
just part of me
and I love every minute of it
so
to summarize I got in all the results
from the club leaders and people and a
lot of people would like
um to retain Nike
uh membership
but by leaving the TAA unless I go
direct to the to the ikikai and that is
the same places where the hombu dojos
located
um we'll have to go and just stick to
purely UK certification
so I've given it a lot of thought
and the percentage is so low who's
bothered about ikikai
um
that I've decided I'll I'll tell you
brief now I've decided to just go UK
certify
certification only
one or two people have said that they
may have to leave the organization and
follow another Obama teacher where they
can get ikakai
recognition and if that's what they must
do that's what they must do
I'd like to just uh
tell you why I've come to this
conclusion
some of the letters I've had they're
saying well we don't follow the style of
the ikikai
because they put the ikikai as the hombu
style of Aikido where actually it's
nothing to do with that it's an umbrella
a sense he formed it there's an umbrella
of all the different styles of Aikido
at least that he said we can all be
agreeing that we can all be under one
umbrella so it's not really Associated
only in people's minds
that's the style of the Homewood dojo
but
if we link it to this
where people perception is the style
then we would never we've never invited
an ikikai teacher to teach uh humble
style Aikido on any of our seminars we
don't follow
the star of the honbu dojo we follow the
cytosensis iwama
style I'll keep using the word star he
called it while Maria
um so
it's not just the weapons that makes us
uh stand out differently it's also the
target so we don't have the
the flowing big movements where it's
much more healthier cardiovascular wise
and um it's not as in my opinion as as
takamusu he's not takamusu it's not like
the Marshall way
even though it's a really good
style of vikado I've got nothing to
criticize it there and I enjoy watching
it in by some instructors not all but
I'm sure people don't like watching all
the iwama instructors
okay so why did I why have I now decided
that we were a UK certification only and
those who wish to leave I wish you well
and I'm sorry to obviously see you go
but that's your decision
cytosensei made me realize that I must
make this decision
because he said please go and see as
many Masters as you can take from them
the Aikido that you need
he said I'm not a teacher that's going
to teach you
um
a religion I'm not going to teach you
how to find the spiritual path you must
find that for yourself and please search
out your own gurus
this is what he
he said he was there just to teach her
sense his basic form of uh Aikido and
that's what his quest was
but why he told me to make this decision
is from what I've gained from from him
merely when I first met him I was a UK
second-hand certified
and he said oh um so that it doesn't
cause any bad feelings let me give you
first down Nike Kai that way
excuse me that way you can make a link
with canetska sensei in the UK
he will present you with a certificate
you'll make a link and then
um that will save any about
in time my mom said already on the films
into but I'm just trying to summarize
in time I got up to third down with site
of Scentsy but I was for also going
along taking UK certification of fourth
down
I'd got fourth down UK certification
when I got my fourth day so I just
actually decided that he would not honor
the ikikai anymore and he would perform
his own certification
well of course he's my master he said to
me watch like Tony carry on with ikikai
or would you like well Maria
I said Scentsy you're my teacher I
follow you
whatever you give me
you're giving it to me where I get the
paper from is insignificant you're my my
master and you are the one I follow
I just want to jump in here and say that
most of the replies I got back
said the same about me and I'm greatly
honored and I humbled by it thank you
very much
um you've said that you follow me and
whatever I decide
um you will go along with because it's
me who you put your trust in and
hopefully my lineage with such a Sensei
I haven't wasted 50 years for nothing
okay
so going back
I got my fourth down my fifth down from
cytosancy and if I'd have gone back on
his dying death bed I would have got my
sixth down from psycho Sensei so it
would have been up three iwa Maria
certification not I could kind not UK
nothing only his
he passed away
um Sensei Hendrick's thought and kindly
that I should have six Dan
um couldn't get it off him anymore I
wasn't going to follow his son he could
hear her so the only place is either UK
or
um because I was having her as my
teacher at the time
uh we went for the ikakai 6 down
the ike I said yes we of course respect
side of Sensei greatly
um but
you haven't got forth down and fifth
down in ikikai you've got the new one
whoa therefore you must pay for all
three
so I partied with over 2 000 pounds
to get three pieces of paper that I've
added to my wall and
um I'm now covering two walls in my
garage what I may convert as a small
dojo
so they're not just out of sight
so this led me to realize that cytosensi
knew
that I was getting UK certification as
well as his ikikai ones and it didn't
phase him it didn't bother him
so to me
this is a true Master he didn't force
and stipulate that I had to jump through
hoop so I must have this I must have
archicai
I followed him and those of you who
still wish to follow me
I hope that you will accept
that um mice certificates
that we we give in the organization
will be of worth because my name goes
behind them
I'm known around the world good or bad
most places now of me
I've never ever heard of any student in
50 years and there's a lot of students
say they couldn't train a dojo because
they didn't have ikikai normally people
will welcome you with open arms they
don't even ask to see a passport
uh but we're just like the propaganda
around the world that's constantly being
fed to us
we feel that if we don't have ikikai or
some of us
not me
um we wouldn't be able to just keep
training like you know or Aikido
wouldn't be as good
who's it got to be as good as
so I'm kind of wind up this film now
by saying it doesn't matter who you
follow
it's you that becomes
the end result
I have outstanding students
but they've trained fanatically
they train and train
there's not a day go by where they don't
do some form of training
in their Gardens in their Flats you know
they swing the can they go on their
knees and perhaps do some Joe work if
the ceiling's too low
you only get out of it what you're
prepared to put in
so please remember it's not who you
follow
so much as what you give to the art
you cannot be the person that you admire
you can only be the person you are
if you can't spend any more time once a
week that's all you can do but you do
have time before you go to bed you could
swing the can a couple of times put it
down you know there's always some time
you can make so I'm not telling you what
to do I'm just saying
chasing Masters
will not get utero senses Aikido only
your time and effort gets you there yes
some teachers are clearer than others
but
it's a bit like I class myself
as a person waiting at a bus stop and I
just wait for the people to come along
I watch people go through the queue
grades go through the downgrades and
once they've
attained their level
I just watch them and wait for them to
rise to the next level
so I'd essentially once said
you are the only person who can pull a
peg out
and and put it in a higher hole no one
else can do that for you
are your ears only hearing what it can
for the level that you're at the answer
is yes
I talk to all levels but who's hearing
me
I get emails saying car Scentsy that
last film I watched of yours gave me a
light bulb moment
it could be a film from ages ago
I might think oh well I must have said
that thousands of times but that person
had a light bulb moment and they got it
when they were ready
so thank you for supporting us so far I
hope you'll stay with the organization
it's just a small change as far as it's
a piece of paper
and if you feel like you need that piece
of paper saying
that you have an ikikai black belt one
day or you already have it
and I
in a way for sorry that the propaganda
has made you feel that you have to have
it but that's your choice it's your path
your journey thank you for listening and
I wish you well in whatever you do